the gyro can experience well you've done
it's pretty badass
it's the ultimate smart move you know in
terms of like dealing with that
especially like the rock star world is
so strange because it's so image based
with so many you know I mean this a
bunch that don't even want to talk I
have had rock stars that wanted to come
on here but they wanted to only do it at
night and they only wanted to have it
with no video they wanted it to be audio
only
we don't want stick I just want it to be
me
well the it was like they were
cultivating a thing it has to be dark in
the room
I want candles like okay I'm out we're
out we're doing we're gone this is not
yeah that's not but you know yeah I
remember that they probably they were
probably messed up the reason they're
yes the reason they're doing what
they're doing is because something
happened to them earlier on you know an
aggressive you know teacher uncle
somebody that just kind of you know a
dad was drunk you know there's the stuff
that pushes them in that direction to be
you know expressive katrinak controlling
and you know wanting to be acknowledged
and do it exactly my way mm-hmm because
I was powerless as a child yeah for sure
right and then that's the thing you
think you see with actors too and they
finally get some success the the the
whole process of auditioning for things
is so brutal because you just do you
like me do you like me I want you to
like me do I get the part I don't oh and
then you go through this for years and
then finally you do get it and then
finally you're the [ __ ] man like oh
look it's Mike likes the star hello Mike
Mike look we've got your your bagels
ready Mike and your trailers ready and
then Mike is you get get get me a
[ __ ] coffee you look over Mike
anything for you and that people act in
this disproportionate very insane way
and then as they get more and more
famous they they feel like they're
entitled yes this treatment yes yeah
it's real strange yes oh you know and
that and I feel like that's I've seen it
in in our world between bands you know
my bands to listen for a perfect circle
all of them you get two you get two
spots where you
you feel entitled you're arrogant you
are greedy like all those things all
those things are in all of us and you
have to check yourself when they come up
yeah or not and you end up being like
the band's that you you are talking
about yeah it has to be this we won't do
it that's gonna down but well bands are
odd to write because you're managing
personalities you're not just it's not
just like one person with a creative
vision and they put it down you have all
these other people and their ideas and
you gotta work it out together and this
all sorts of weird [ __ ] going on right
sorry what you do we show it off let's
check out my likes no I was making sure
because I posted that Indiana watch when
I make sure Dino knew that did we posted
it because then he can talk to release
oh yeah release dance just is it that
yeah yeah I took that's a lot of work
are ba are we are the four of us are a
lot of [ __ ] work and just to get it
just to get really where Oh
just to get an agreement where you're
okay we're all agreeing yeah we're gonna
release it yeah there everything's a
[ __ ] committee meeting and it always
gets shut down
what's the hurdle
well success when you get successful you
think you're right about everything and
you're pretty sure as that individual
yeah I am right and you are wrong
because I'm successful and very
successful because of me not because of
you and so you it's it's not that bad
with us but it's like that's the dynamic
there's a dynamic of like you know I
want this and I've I've always gotten in
my way and that's why we're successful
because I don't compromise on this or
that and it's like I you know I'm the
same way
[Applause]